now india has been reluctant to
criticize russia and its invasion of
ukraine while that has angered western
allies like the u.s experts say india's
position reflects historical economic
ties between itself and russia
the defense industry and increasingly
the oil industry
india is the world's leading buyer of
arms
until last year it accounted for 11
percent of total global arms imports
according to the stockholm international
peace research institute cipri
its biggest supplier was russia
between 2017 and 2021 it accounted for
46 of indian arms imports and in the
previous five-year period russia
accounted for more than two-thirds of
indian arms imports
india has been trying to reduce its
dependence on russian arms and diversify
suppliers
if you look at other countries let that
are saying europe
france britain
japan they're all dependent on the us
for their security
okay india is not dependent on the u.s
foreign security india is certainly
likes u.s political support
but
at the end of the day india
depends on itself
so it is self-interest which is driving
indian policy i don't think any ideology
drives it
joshi says moscow also supported india's
foreign policy in the region before and
after the collapse of the soviet union
but that's not the only reason
self-interest may be behind new delhi's
choice to remain neutral on russia's war
in ukraine
india imports 80 percent of its oil
needs and rising oil prices have already
led to protests so while other countries
spurn russian oil india is buying it
so far it has bought at least 13 million
barrels according to bloomberg news and
without that many takers of russian oil
india may very well benefit from lower
prices
i asked our delhi correspondent chari
charu kartike about western criticisms
of india for buying russian crude at a
discount is india on the wrong side of
history as the u.s has said
well chelsea india has not really
registered a formal response to that
very specific comment about buying uh
crude from russia but uh foreign affairs
minister
s jashankar made the statement in
parliament yesterday and he said that
india's stand on ukraine has been very
consistent india is consistently
reiterating that
hostilities and violence need to end and
at the same time india has been
asserting that the global order is based
on the u.n charter and respect for the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
all countries about oil all that india
has said is that it's
the uh component of russian oil in
india's import basket is less than one
percent and it doesn't really matter
much to the trade but yes there are
reports that uh you know 13 million
barrels of uh oil have been uh bought
and several indian companies have gone
ahead and placed those orders uh
there are reports that russia is
offering oil at a discount of 27 percent
and india is thinking about or planning
to use uh those uh oil stocks for
shoring up its strategic uh oil reserves
chelsea
russia and india are also reportedly
working on a rupee ruble payment
mechanism for that oil how significant
is that
well yeah uh that's very significant uh
chelsea that's and that because uh uh
since trade is continuing between india
and russia uh the payment systems need
to be finalized several exporters in
india as well as in russia have said
that this rupee ruble mechanism that
existed years ago needs to be brought
back because a large number of russian
banks have been cut off from the swift
system and that is impeding payments now
the tricky thing is that
both the currencies need to be pegged to
a third currency so that some kind of
exchange rate can be worked out indian
exporters
have been asking the reserve bank of
india which is india's central bank to
work out this exchange rate so that
their
payments do not suffer
some experts also believe chelsea that
this rupee ruble trade is already going
on because
the governments have been very uh
secretive about it there has not been
clear-cut information from either size
but many believe that payments are
already being made in rubles to russia
so yes that's something the government
as of now has already said that owen has
only said that several payment
mechanisms are being looked at there is
a team intra-ministerial team that is uh
looking into formulating a strategy and
it will be announced soon chelsea
is that a signal that india might be
looking to boost trade with russia and
more than just oil
well chelsea that's
a little bit hard to say because in any
case apart from
the arms trade with russia oil is the
biggest component of uh indo russian
trade apart from that uh
india also buys sunflower oil
which is uh whose prices also have been
going up in india so if if that is also
offered at a discounted rate india will
be
india will likely be tempted to continue
doing that trade fertilizers are also
something that india continues to buy
from russia so i think what india is
looking at right now is to maintain this
trade relationship and not really
it it's not really planning to expand it
further uh but at least maintain uh the
the uh the items that are being bought
from russia and if they are being
offered at a discounted rate that's
that's be very good for the indian
economy that's what the government
appears to be contemplating right now